[Musica]
ciao a tutti mi chiamo francesco e
questa è la mia più grande paura
ok è un foglio bianco e quindi
probabilmente sembro uno un po strano ma
lasciatevi spieghi questa è la mia più
grande paura perché io nella vita faccio
l'illustratore faccio l'illustratore ma
non lo faccio da sempre ci sono arrivato
e ci sono arrivato facendo un percorso
un po tortuoso e questa sera mi prendo
il lusso di spiegarvelo non ho fatto
nessun tipo di studio artistico perché
quando ero bambino disegnavo e disegnavo
in continuazione qualunque illustratore
vi direbbe disegno da che ho memoria
ecco io forse persino dapprima perché
mia mamma mi raccontati portavo
all'asilo tutte le mattine i bambini
erano in giro giocavano facevano un
casino incredibile e tutte le sante
mattine andavi dalla maestra dice vi
posso disegnare ti mettevi in un angolo
e disegna v poi però succede quella cosa
bizzarra che va sotto il nome di
adolescenza e lì le cose cambiano io
nello specifico durante l'adolescenza
pensavo che sarei diventato un
romanziere uno scrittore o qualcosa di
simile quindi ho studiato ho fatto il
liceo classico
ho studiato lettere moderne a dirla
tutta ho fatto un pò finta di fare
lettere moderne nel senso che vanta un
invidiabile record di cinque esami in
cinque anni e potete serenamente capire
da soli perché sono stati gli anni più
belli della mia vita
[Applauso]
dopo quei cinque anni mio padre mi ha
dato la più classica delle pedate nel
sedere mi ha detto ora basta con questa
farsa trovati qualcosa da fare e mi sono
messo a fare quei lavori che fai quando
non hai nessun tipo di professionalità
specifica
sono stato un
pony express ho lavorato nel marketing
telefonico può essere che una sera abbia
chiamato a casa qualcuno di voi cercando
di venderli qualcosa
il lavoro più stabile che trovai in quel
periodo fu l'uomo delle pulizie facevo
l'uomo delle pulizie in un ufficio e
quindi tutte le sere quando l'ufficio si
svuotava arrivavo io pulivo le scrivanie
i bagni i pavimenti e portavo a casa
in questo modo la pagnotta in
quell'ufficio fatto l'incontro che in
qualche maniera cambiato il senso della
mia storia perché in quell'ufficio ho
incontrato un piccolo mac ed era un mac
di vent'anni fa quindi sensibilmente
diverso dagli strumenti che siamo
abituati a utilizzare oggi è il fatto è
che all'epoca avevo due cose soprattutto
un sacco di tempo libero e la mattina
dopo potevo dormire e tanta curiosità
quella ce l'ho ancora e quindi quando
finivo le mie pulizie accendevo il mac
per capire come funzionasse per capire
che cosa potevo combine arci ed è
successo che in qualche maniera
quel piccolo mac è quella cosa che
continuava a fare per me stesso tutti i
giorni disegnare come se fosse una
terapia personale mi sembrava potessero
parlare un linguaggio comune
mi sembrava avessero dei punti in comune
a furia di lavorare su quel computer
tutte le sere mi sono un po inventato
una professione di garda grafico e vi
assicuro che è una parola grossa per
quello che combinava all'epoca però
fatto sta che proprio in quell'ufficio
ho iniziato a fare il grafico perché ho
scoperto che in quell'ufficio mancava un
grafico lo cercavano non lo trovavano e
quindi una sera ho fatto una grafica
bruttissima di cui si sono assolutamente
per fortuna perse le tracce e l'ho
lasciata sul tavolo del capo di
quell'ufficio con un post it con scritto
sono quello che fare pulizia la notte ma
se serve posso fare anche questo
erano messi così male sostanzialmente
che mi dissero va bene da domani mattina
cominci e quindi è di accesso legale a
quel computer e con la luce del giorno
il che migliorò notevolmente la qualità
della mia vita e per una decina d'anni
ho fatto il grafico fatto tantissima
grafica disegnare era una
passione mia personale era la mia
terapia ma lo facevo lo tenevo in un
cassetto in gran parte per timidezza e
in parte perché ero assolutamente
convinto che non esistesse uno così
matto là fuori da darmi dei soldi per i
miei disegnini cosa succede a questo
punto a questo punto dopo dieci anni di
grafica dovete immaginare le grafiche
peggiori dal volantino della pizzeria
sotto casa a cose anche più divertenti
succede qualcosa che ha a che fare col
caso oppure con un'altra parola sempre
di quattro lettere che inizia per ci
finisce però mannone caso perché capita
che da grafico faccio una copertina per
una rivista una rivista per cui lavoravo
che si chiamava rivista ufficiale nba
era la rivista ufficiale della in b e in
italia la faccio e questa copertina
viene ripresa da un blog editoriale che
la pubblica tra le migliori copertine
della settimana
io felicissimo già così dovevo capire
che il bello doveva ancora venire perché
dopo qualche giorno da quella
pubblicazione su quel blog mi arriva una
mail di un tale che si qualifica come un
art director del new york times magazine
e mi dice ho visto la copertina sul blog
è bellissima non conoscevo la tua
rivista e io dico ma come a new york non
conoscete rivista ufficiale nba con a
questa cosa gli rispondo io la tua l'ho
sentita nominare a new york times ok mi
dice qualcosa
iniziamo a chiacchierare via mail
parlando di grafica parlando di design
editoriale parlando di basket io faccio
finta di essere uno che di basket ne sa
tantissimo per mantenere la
conversazione attiva e dopo un po di
mail
prendo il coraggio a due mani e gli
mando un messaggio dicendogli senti a
questo link
trovi un po di disegnini che faccio per
me che faccio nel tempo libero
siccome non mi ricapita un'altra volta
di parlare così con uno del tuo livello
sai che c'è ho bisogno di consigli ho
bisogno nel caso di schiaffoni ho
bisogno che tu mi dica se questa cosa
che faccio è che mi piace tanto a un
senso oppure no
lui non risponde per un paio di giorni e
di solito era molto rapido nelle
risposte io penso di aver rovinato una
meravigliosa amicizia e invece dopo due
giorni mi manda una mail che credo
ricorderò per sempre perché mi scrive
francesco dei sei timing is everything
dicono che il tempismo è tutto nella
vita penso che tu sia perfetto per farmi
un mitt romney will beall web all
la vostra più o meno la stessa reazione
che ho avuto io perché mitt romney ok lo
sapevo era il presidente il candidato
nella corsa presidenziale contro obama
ma un web bollo hubble
diciamocelo cosa diamine uibo luogo
grazie a dio tra le cose meravigliose
che l'uomo ha inventato c'è una cosa che
si chiama google immagini tu ci vai
sopra scrivi uibo lo hubble e scopri che
è quello che noi chiameremmo ercolino
sempre in piedi sono quei pupazzi che
anche quando gli dai una botta tornano
sempre al loro posto li voleva che
disegna assi un mitt romney dentro un
uibo lo hubble dentro uno di questi
giocattoli ci lavoriamo a distanza per
non più di due o tre giorni dopo 23
giorni mi scrive mi dice perfetto e il
tuor mitt romney ha approvato e aggiunge
a chiusura del della mail
francesco è un made the cover e io li
scrive
in che senso i'm the cover è lui a non
te l'ho detto è il tuo mitt romney uibo
lo hubble va sulla copertina del new
york times magazine
[Applauso]
io come potete immaginare o dapprima un
mancamento
poi dopo i sali mi riprendo e capisco
due cose quando esce questa copertina la
prima che forse quei disegni neely
insomma non sono così male se possono
finire sulla copertina di un giornale
del genere e la seconda che devo mettere
da parte la timidezza mettere su quella
che a milano chiamiamo faccia di tolla e
fare sapere a tutti che ho fatto questa
cosa per cui iniziò a mandare mail a
chiunque ma quando dico chiunque intende
chiunque anche mia zia dicendo zia non
ci vediamo da natale ma sai cosa è
successo ho fatto la copertina del new
york times e da lì in un circolo
virtuoso l'illustrazione diventa il mio
lavoro diventa il mio fortunatissimo
modo di pagare le bollette e in questo
mi sento un privilegiato un privilegiato
assoluto perché ho la sfacciata fortuna
di essere pagato per fare quello che amo
ma non pensate che essere un
illustratore sia fragole e panna tutti i
giorni non immaginatemi seduto su una
nuvoletta mentre sorseggio prosecco con
una mano e disegno quello che ho voglia
di disegnare con l'altra non è così
essere un illustratore e molto meno
simile ad essere un artista che ad altro
è molto più simile ad essere mister wolf
di pulp fiction
ciao sono francesco risolvo problemi
perché hai sempre a che fare con una
committenza dall'altra parte c'è un
cliente che ti pone un problema e tu
cerchi di risolverlo e per risolvere i
problemi dei miei clienti
io devo affrontare quotidianamente la
mia più grande paura quella del foglio
bianco e come lo faccio ho capito che
per farlo serve metodo non si può
improvvisare
l'ispirazione non è una cosa per la
quale sei seduto sotto un albero ti
casca una mela in testa e o ti viene
un'idea l'ispirazione ha bisogno di
metodo picasso diceva l'ispirazione
esiste ma deve trovarci al lavoro ed è
esattamente quello il punto bisogna
lavorare sulla propria ispirazione anche
perché
facendo questo esercizio io ho scoperto
che la creatività è un muscolo
esattamente come tutti gli altri ed
esattamente come tutti i muscoli
funzioni in un solo modo se i continui
ad allenarlo ed è il motivo per cui io
cerco di tenere sempre allenata la mia
creatività come lo faccio tenendo la
mente aperta riempiendola di cose belle
guardando belle illustrazioni leggendo
buoni libri ascoltando buona musica
bevendo un ottimo aperitivo con gli
amici perché sono tutti stimoli che
servono a nutrire la mia creatività che
possono tornarvi utile quando ho bisogno
di risolvere un problema a me stesso o
ai miei clienti facendo questo esercizio
ho scoperto una serie di cose
meravigliose perché ho scoperto per
esempio che quando si dice fare il passo
più lungo della gamba che è la sostanza
della creatività succede una cosa
incredibile
succede che le gambe si allungano e
quando le gambe si allungano ti portano
verso nuovi territori e andare verso
nuovi territori vuol dire imparare
parole nuove
vuol dire crearsi un vocabolario di
parole nuove che non conosce vie che
impari a conoscere ea usare e quando usi
parole nuove
puoi anche raccontare storie nuove e
devi farlo sempre con la tua personalità
con la tua voce perché non mi interessa
seguire la moda del momento disegnare
come disegna qualcun altro mi interessa
dire le cose che mi interessano dire con
la mia voce e ho scoperto che questo è
fondamentale perché è molto più
importante essere felici che essere
belli perché la felicità resta mentre le
mode passano
questa è la mia sfida stasera parliamo
di sfide io vi ho raccontato la mia e
oggi ha raccontato anche come faccio ad
affrontarla tutti i giorni per cui
adesso vi posso dire che sono francesco
faccio l'illustratore è quella mia paura
grande quel foglio bianco mi fa un po
meno paura
grazie